[Music]
well welcome to leadership society
reimagining work post covid um today
we're talking about works hold on us
firing the office and freeing the
workers um today i have two guests um
anu parthenon
you can correct that i hope that's okay
and then
uh karen arnold um so anu is a
journalist based in new york city um
she's been there doing that for more
than a decade and she's the author of a
book the nordic theory of everything
we'll have a chance to talk about that a
little bit uh and then karen is the head
of talent at automatic
that the people behind wordpress.com
jetpack woocommerce tumblr and and many
other organizations um so thank you both
for taking the time to be with me
yeah for sure it's great to be here
great so um karen i'm gonna start with
you so automatic is a distributed
company can you tell us what that means
yeah definitely um automatic is about um
15 almost 16 years old or 16 years old i
hope i have that right and we've been
distributed since the very beginning
we also you know people use the word
remote a lot but distributed is a little
different in the sense that when the
company first started
the founder essentially his vision for
work was that everybody could work where
they
where they were most comfortable where
they were able to do the best kind of
work wherever that was that was in their
house or if that was in a co-working
space whatever country like it didn't
matter right there's never been a
corporate office
all of our meetings happen
online in some way either zoom or back
back in those days before zoom
over skype and whatever kinds of tools
we had available
so that distributed sense is slightly
different from remote work
in that it's truly just
distributed everywhere there's no
central organization where people come
together
so yeah essentially just doing the work
that we need to do for the company
gathering with whatever various tools
are available at the time to
move the work
forward got it and um
why why was this why did the why was the
thought that this was the best way to do
it
i mean i can't speak to what what our
founder matt thought at the time but
but essentially
it's always been a driving sort of
value for us that
talent
is everywhere talent is all over the
world right
distributed in whatever country whatever
corner of the world but opportunity
isn't
so
his
his sense was to bring those
opportunities to the talent that was
available and and i think a lot of it
grew out of you know we're we're
sort of
founded grounded i should say in the
open source wordpress community um many
of us that we're at that start that you
know started at automatic in the early
days came from that wordpress open
source community and that open source
community was already distributed around
the world um
and yeah so essentially just
making sure that opportunities are
available for any of the people that can
do it and that doesn't mean you know
those people aren't all in one city in
one country
yeah so you know every policy has cost
and benefits right so i you're talking
about the benefits of that what's the
biggest cost to the workforce
of this policy do you think
you know i didn't really see the the
the biggest i don't know if it's the
biggest cost but i didn't really see
that cost until covid
set upon us
and that was that
we had this
ability to
do this work online
text-based communication zoom calls and
then we would get together every once in
a while so it was kind of the tradition
at automattic that i don't know three to
four weeks out of the year we spent that
time together in person
and so we never really sort of noticed
any kind of a cost we feel like we can
move projects forward and get things
done really swiftly actually you know we
work really really i mean our momentum
at automatic is really swift
um but suddenly when we had that piece
taken away
or we couldn't get together face-to-face
we really saw that really hit us a lot
more that you know that's that's
probably one of the things it's like
there comes a point where human beings
need to get together face to face to
work on things and there's a different
cadence for how you can do that work
when you are in the same room
yeah so the the missing of the being
together that's that's the from your
perspective yeah yeah yeah
so i'm curious about your your
experience of um american work culture
so you wrote a book the nordic figure of
everything and i assume that was in part
because you saw a very different you had
a very different experience in the u.s
so i'm curious about your
perception of the u.s work experience
yeah um i'm actually in helsinki right
now and i'm currently working um in
finland for a finnish company
but yeah so i moved to the united states
now already more than
13 years ago and i i lived in the us for
10 years and now i'm based in helsinki
again
um
the work culture obviously is extremely
different in the nordic countries
overall in finland where i am right now
and in the united states and especially
perhaps in a city like new york city
where people work extremely hard and
really are ambitious and come to the
city to work hard
but for me
i remember
at first when i started hearing
americans talk about jobs and whether
they come with benefits or not for me
that was already
i was thinking of like a gym membership
or something and i was like i don't
really
why are they talking about benefits so
much i didn't understand that it meant
healthcare because in the nordic
countries uh healthcare is universal
healthcare and it has nothing to do with
your job but i think that was like one
of the first moments for me to realize
that americans are much more dependent
on their employers than the nordic
people are and that sort of sets the
stage
for
very different work life obviously um
americans work a lot more longer hours
i think often feel much more
dependent on their employer for more
things than the nordic people too
which is also tied to other social
policies so
paid parental leaves in the nordic
countries every parent has a right to
pay parentally regardless of who your
employer is how big they are whereabouts
in the country you are
everybody has the same right to paid
vacation days
people have the right to work shorter
hours if the child is for example under
the age of eight
so there's a lot of
these protections for workers that allow
you to combine work and family much
better than in the united states where
of course people often are sort of
afraid of getting fired if they don't
work hard enough
so i think all that just creates an
extremely different
um work life experience having said that
i really admire the way americans often
also um see their work as a passion or
people are extremely ambitious and
really like to work hard and get results
i mean that's amazing if it is really
something that you want to do i think in
nordic countries people can have a
little bit more of a distance between
the job and their sort of
persona it seemed to me in the nordic
countries people often think that you
know they work hard and the northern
countries are successful countries with
successful businesses
but
people still think that the their free
time is extremely valuable and they're
more than happy to
turn off the computer when the day is
done and so on so it's sort of a mixture
i think of of social policy that impacts
your relationship with your employer and
then on the other hand the culture that
evolves around it on how you think about
work
and how much you think you should be
working
and how do you how do you do um
something like distributed work
in in finland or in other countries and
how did how does that work is it do you
think it's is it different if you know
if you've experienced it in the states
you mean the the how the work is
arranged yeah so if you do
like as karen's company does distributed
work so it's fully it's remote but it's
more than just that but do you do that
kind of work in finnish or in nordic um
companies and if so do you think it's
does it operate differently than it does
in the united states
i think we do it more now because of
kobit i think before not at all as much
um now it seems like it's of course
astonishing i think everywhere in the
world how it's become the norm really
but it wasn't so much before which is
actually surprising if you think of the
sort of that nordic countries are very
technologically advanced and overall
sort of quite progressive in many ways
but but working from home wasn't really
something that was extremely common but
now of course it is for example at my
office um this whole kobe time
we've been working from home and we can
go to the office um if we want to
there's a lot of people actually who
have all through this covid period gone
to the office and a lot of them have
been sort of single younger people who
live close to the office who don't live
with anyone else maybe or live with
roommates and they really enjoy and want
to go to the office to see other people
and then there's a lot of people like me
who have small children who don't live
right next to the office and who are
more than happy actually because it
saves time in commuting and makes life
in many ways easier to work from home so
in the end i think the transition
actually has gone quite smoothly but but
i don't think before it was at all the
kind of um setup that current was
describing i think that was quite rare
at the time
yeah did i ask because and this is a
kindness for you i asked because my
experience is that it's really hard to
stop working when you have when you can
work from home right i mean there's no
the dividing line between work and the
rest of your life which can be in the
states already a little bit soft and
blurry can just evaporate completely
right and so how do you i mean this is
for you and for your organization how do
you
draw those boundaries i mean are people
working all the time are they working
more than they would be if they were
just coming to the office and then going
home how does that work for your company
yeah i think as honor was talking you
know you you asked um
brian you asked earlier about the cost
and i just it clicked well and it was
talking that's the cost
of distributed work is overwork
it just
you know and
not because
yeah
so how do you define like the boundaries
it's something we talk about a lot
burnout is always a thing that we've
that we've discussed over all the years
that i've been at automatic all of the
years that automatic has been in
existence
because it's easy to do that when you're
home just doing your own thing and your
computer is always there and i mean
unless you have a work laptop and a
personal laptop you open your laptop to
go check your personal email and work is
right there
just a click away
and there's always something going on
especially when you're working in a
company where people live all around the
world
somebody's awake in the middle of their
work day and it's 10 30 p.m for you
so do you check in and do something
really quickly or do you walk away so
yeah creating those boundaries it's
really it's just training and practice
and communication
self-awareness
and just trying to figure out you know
what works for you for for one person it
might work to be able to spread their
work day out throughout the day work a
little run some errands work a little
run some errands that's fine they love
it they thrive on that for other people
they've got
you know responsibilities outside of
work like kids or you know elderly
parents that they're taking care of and
so they have to have more firm
boundaries we just try
to be as intentional as possible
about
making sure that people have permission
to do the things that they need to do
and then we give them the support to be
away
and like truly away when they need to be
away but around when they when they want
to be around and let people kind of set
those you know just always checking in
with people to make sure that that kind
of stuff is happening
um and i'm the work i can talk about
this for hours and i'm the worst
personally
at those boundaries i think i've been
working from home for way too long
yeah because it also seems competitive
right so you want to be successful and
you're looking around to see how much
other people are doing so it seems
really hard to just personally draw
boundaries if you see other people
working harder and i also wonder about
this because you said you're around the
world right so there have to also be
global differences i mean even right now
we're talking to honor like and how
people work in different cultures like
how do you manage the global differences
again i think just communication
inviting people to be open about what it
is that they need
uh talk about those cultural differences
and and and different types of approach
to work and and just
yeah just transparent as being as
transparent and open and inclusive as we
possibly can about the conversation so
that people can get out but they need to
get out
and anna do you expect this looks you
said you now are working remotely and
it's great because you don't have to
commute and other people like it not so
that so much but do you expect this to
affect the work culture in in nordic
countries or in finland
well the nordic twist on this is what
people have been sort of openly talking
about that this is going to kill our
paid sick days in a sense because nobody
takes a sick day anymore because you can
work from home unless you're of course
completely like
knocked out in bed and you can't work
but the regular in the past i mean in
the nordic countries you always have a
right to paid sick day if you're sick
and you don't even you know for three
days you can stay home without even a
doctor's note so if you had a cold you
would stay home and
and like not open your computer now of
course this
i think i don't know if employers even
have that expectation but i think most
people working in sort of professional
fields would feel like well there's no
reason for me not to work if it's just
that i have a little bit of you know
sniffles or a cough
as to the work time
i think that's a danger but at least in
my company and and i had a team working
for me i have been very clear
with the more junior members of my team
saying that you know i might send in
emails and notes in the evening because
i might do that after my child goes to
bed i do not expect you to answer them
and
and i basically told that if our ceo
sends you a message in the evening or on
the weekend that's fine do not answer it
you're not expected to the fact that
because of course there's concern like
you're saying that people feel that if
other people are working oh this is the
company culture is especially for more
junior members
that oh i'm expected to be online all
the time and i think
in the nordic countries overall there's
perhaps more than in the united states
sort of clear sense that that's not
really expected and we should say that
out loud that people should be able to
work during the work hours and not be
always online i think so far
it works okay but of course it's true
that this this culture also impacts how
it's harder to draw the boundaries
we'll see how that goes once you have to
say it out loud not to do it you already
know you have a problem
maybe maybe yeah we've had a few
trainees like responding to messages in
the evening and you're like nope don't
do that
um so i i also you
about the nordic policies the kind of
policies you talked about some of the
universal social policies health care um
kind of family leave those sorts of
things and you talk about it as in
everyone's self-interest
like what does that mean because it
doesn't like when we talk about
self-interest in the states certainly
paying high taxes for other people so
they can they can have um family leave
is not considered you know in in
people's self-interest can you say more
about what you mean by that
well i think the key to that is to
understand the the whole of the nordic
society and sort of how all these um
social services work
um because it's not just individual
policies if you look at just paid leave
or subsidized day care then you might
raise the question that oh if i don't
have kids then why am i helping out in
my taxes helping somebody else's
parental leave or so on
but because in the nordic countries
there's a fairly wide
range of sort of social services there's
education there's the daycare the basic
education there's not really any private
schools in finland or kids go to public
school college is free they even pay you
a stipend the government while you're
studying so people don't really have
huge student loans
um healthcare is taxpayer funded so it
becomes this whole package that follows
you basically from cradle to grave and
everybody gets something out of it even
if you don't have children and there's
some benefits you're not using for your
own children because you don't have them
but maybe you use them as a child or
maybe you are the person who got a phd
and everybody else paid for it so i
think that's sort of the key to thinking
that everybody feels that okay i pay my
taxes and i get something in return it
might not be the same thing for
everybody but everybody gets something
so then you don't feel like you're only
contributing and others are using so i
think that's sort of the problem when in
the united states for example when i
started working on the book a lot of
people told me that that i should write
a book about education because finland
at the time was very well known for
um
excelling in the piece of study which
surveys 15 year olds in different
countries and tries to compare how good
the basic
public education system is
and the finns always did really well and
the world was very interested in finnish
education system but to me it felt sort
of pointless to just try to look at the
education system
because it starts in daycare it starts
with the paid parental leave it's about
free school lunches it's about your path
after school and all that ties together
so i think that is also part of the
feeling that people feel like okay i am
this is all in my self-interest even if
there's one thing that i'm not taking
part in
got it so in the states i mean you know
this you you live here long enough but
the idea would be sure self-interest is
really pay me more money don't give me
don't tax that money heavily and let me
pay for my own you know let me decide
how i want to spend that money if i want
to pay for daycare i'll pay for daycare
if i want to take time off in vacation i
i can i can do that well we can't do
that so well but we can we can buy
services that are that fit our personal
needs right that's self-interest and
there's a concern that if we allow these
things to be managed by the government
they will be sub-par like we should have
organizations competing to provide the
best services and then allowing people
to choose
how they want to use those services by
paying like what's wrong with that where
is that where is that wrong from your
perspective
well i think that sounds great in theory
but ending practice if you look at the
services we're talking about
health care education it's not like
buying jeans it's not that oh your kid
went to three years to a school and you
all of a sudden realize that they didn't
learn anything oh i'll just return this
education and get a better one like you
can't you lose so much
if the investment is wrong and the same
with healthcare how can you actually
compete with buying the best cancer care
i mean it's impossible you don't you're
not an expert you can't really compare
the different treatments you can't
compare doctors
it's too expensive for you often to
really be able to compete and of course
in the united states as everybody knows
you have your health insurance companies
that then limit your choices so many of
these
extremely essential social services that
everybody needs to become a you know
functional person in life and be healthy
and get the education they need and have
to get the support they need for their
children they're not easy to compare
they're not easy to buy they can be very
expensive that's sort of my argument
that in the nordic countries people have
basically outsourced the logistics of
quality of control of wholesale buying
of providing them for everyone to the
government and of course you want them
to be really high quality and i
understand the american concern that
they're not going to be look at some of
the american services i mean i've been
dmv or whatnot and it does not work so
well so you feel like well government is
the problem but if you look at the
services in the nordic countries and the
results they produce in international
surveys i mean nordic countries
typically are
topping all the surveys of how well
students have learned in education or
how healthy people are what the gender
equality looks like so the results are
actually really good so i don't think
there's anything
in government that would not be able to
provide high quality services if you
give them the resources and of course if
citizens are vigilant and demand
services i mean if you you ask finnish
people about
how things are going they are going to
complain so much is actually really
annoying because you look at if you take
any perspective you go to most other
countries in the world or you look at
any international service you can see
that people in the northern countries
actually have a very high quality of
life but you wouldn't know that if you
talk to finnish people
and partly as annoying as i sometimes
find it i think that's also the key
people really think that i need deserve
high quality service and if i don't get
it my politicians are going to pay
so that i would argue that actually
sometimes you have more power
as a citizen to impact the quality of
services than you might have as a
customer who's trying to buy health care
or trying to deal with a health
insurance company by yourself
um and this i have a question that i
don't know if this is fair but i'll ask
it anyway so you have a lot of
policies that are about families right
so there's paid family leave support for
education but the birth rate in in
finland or nordic countries is not that
much higher than the birth rate in
places that don't have those kind of
support services like what's the thought
about that like i mean because often in
the states we'll talk about like people
can't have kids because they can't
afford to or we don't have services but
you look at places like finland that
have incredible services for families
and you still don't see higher birth
rates i'm just curious about
your thoughts on that yeah
that's in a way a bit of a mystery i
think there's always headlines in
finland about that and researchers are
trying to explain why aren't people
having more children because they could
like exactly comparatively to other
places in the world having agile this
easier and the society provides for you
and you can still have a job and a
career but it just seems to me that
that's a trend that is happening in all
western countries even in the united
states where people
women study longer people wait until to
have children they end up having
fewer children
i'm not really sure if indian social
policy really can impact that right now
in finland i think the young people are
extremely aware of climate change i mean
as we speak this uh students young
people demonstrating the streets they've
cut off the traffic in downtown helsinki
because they really want the finnish
government to declare uh climate
emergency and start acting on it
so
i mean it's a real concern that a lot of
young people actually because of these
questions don't really see a great
future for having children or are
thinking that well the world's you know
the planet's going to hell
uh how much is a paid parent gonna help
you in that case but
it's a good question you think in a way
that that if you have really good
social services and opportunities to
have children people would have more
children but it doesn't really seem to
work that way in any western countries
and kind of think think about the
benefits that different countries
provide like how do you support your
employees so they're distributed they're
all over the world like what kind of um
support do you provide or benefits
that's rather do you provide provide
your workers how do you think about this
as they live in different different
places under different systems
yeah and i'm not directly involved in
that because i sort of function outside
of hr human resources department is the
one that manages that more than anything
but
essentially just broad strokes
we
have several we have entities
in several countries so once we hit
more or less when we hit kind of a
threshold when we have a certain number
of people within a certain country do
some prep work and exploratory work um
and try to figure out a way to have a
local entity there so that folks can can
be employees of that entity
so for example you know the united
states australia
a number of other countries
and
outside of that
folks are international contractors and
they're
as far as we consider employees they're
treated the exact same they're not don't
treat them as a different level of a
different class of employee
but according to their
country they're then responsible to take
care of
their own
taxes follow the laws of their country
in terms of work um and we give support
for that as much as we can
that's your question yeah then that
answers my question
so i just have just a couple more
questions one i'm i'm curious about your
both of your thoughts on
what do you think
is the proper role of work in people's
lives
like i'll start with you karen like how
do you how do you think people should
think about work like i you know i'm i'm
i live in the states like you go out
somewhere people ask you what you do
like your identity is who you are is
really wrapped up in your work um often
people get really excited about retiring
and it turns out when people retire
they're often not they don't do well
because they lost a significant part of
their identity their identity
yes i'm curious like you know at a place
like um automatic you're you know
us-based but all over the world you're
thinking about how people should engage
with work
what do you what would you tell someone
who's coming in or just starting their
career like how should they
think about themselves and work
i don't know if it's because i'm so
you know united states oriented i mean
it's like so deep in my
you know
sort of sense of of who who i am i
didn't even grow up in the united states
but you know my parents were born and
raised in the u.s and i was raised very
much in a you know us kind of you know
tradition so i don't know any other way
to engage with work other than to throw
my entire self
into it
i you know i don't know how to do it any
differently from that
um you know you hear about like honor
you're talking about other places where
that's slightly a slightly different
approach and i think wow
wow i wish i could have a little bit of
that um
i think you know i yeah i'd like i said
i don't know any other way to do it but
but i do know it's important to support
other people's
approach too right like not everybody
has to approach work the way that i do
where like if i didn't feel passionate
about the work that automatic does i
didn't feel bought into
you know our our culture of our
mission to democratize the web
democratize
e-commerce and really help people get
done on the internet what they need to
get done
i wouldn't be able to work at automatic
uh-huh you're head of talent right so
you yeah yeah so when you look for
someone so this i'm curious about this
when you look for someone you're looking
for people to work there and you meet
people you're like let's let's imagine
you're interviewing them and you you
meet two people one person is like you
know i i want to do a great job but it's
important for me to have a life outside
of work and you meet someone else who's
like i am dedicated you know mind body
and soul to what i'm going to do in this
organization
like who are you going to choose
both of them
no but seriously both of them really
because they they're both
they're both going to bring value to
what it is that we do and we have both
of those kinds of people at automatic i
think in the early days we had only the
the
the latter right the one that was like
super driven throwing mind body and soul
i think in the early days that's what
automatic looked like really
um and as it grew it shifted a little
bit you were much bigger i mean when i
started at automatic we were about 100
and some people and now we're 1700
something almost 1800 i think and um
you know we have all we have
a whole diverse
approach to work now and i think there's
room for both of those people at
automatic
and in fact the ones that throw
themselves mind body and soul into the
work what they'll discover when they
come to work at automatic is that they
are supported
to take you know i take vacation
[Laughter]
karen you don't take work with you tell
the truth no i really i really don't but
but this is a thing
like i said i'm i'm not the person who
should really necessarily explain to
people how to divide work
in life
it's been during covid when i have
really realized
the importance of
just closing the laptop and walking away
and not checking in for if i'm taking a
week off like that is a week of vacation
so
you know silver linings i guess
good
global crises um yeah
and what about you andy what if you're
going to tell someone they're starting
off
they're young they want to be successful
like what should their relationship to
work be
well i think for most of us of course in
any country work is important because
it's a way to feel useful it's way to be
connected to society it gives a status
but there is a lot of discussion in the
nordic countries and in finland of of
ideas like basic income and whether the
current model of work really is the only
one that that should give you meaning or
should that you should be seen as a
productive member of society if you have
a traditional job
if you had basic income perhaps people
would be finding other ways to be useful
in a society that wouldn't be the same
kind of work structure that we have now
but of course even in the nordic
countries currently the whole system
works that people work and pay taxes and
then get services in return so it's
there's also this constant debate that
it's it's important uh to have people
working in a more traditional manner so
that's
still up in the air how future
generations will feel about it
i myself when i went to my current job
and i went for the job interview i
actually told them that i have a small
child
i'm not gonna be
uh online in the evenings and i mostly
even though i said earlier that
sometimes i might be most of the time
i'm not i just i'm gonna deal with it in
the morning whatever it is and that's
fine in our company when i was younger i
used to work a lot so i think just like
karen was saying there's different kinds
of people who have different kind of
life situation and and
can or want to throw themselves in the
work uh at different levels and it can
be the same person at different points
of their life
and that's fine and i think an
organization is all the better for it if
they have different kinds of people but
so i guess that would be my take i think
i personally think and i think it's very
nordic way of thinking that it is very
important for people to also take time
off relax
have a hobby see people because burnout
person who's like singularly focused on
work is not necessarily going to be the
most creative or
or
necessarily the most productive worker
in the end of course there are great
examples of people who are extremely
focused and driven and get great results
but overall i think it's a really good
thing if people can also just
turn their computer laptops off yeah and
do something else
so um
that's so this is a kind of segue you
can maybe refine your answers a little
bit based on on the comments you both
made but we've gone through
covid right and it's really changed how
people have engaged right um and you
both alluded to that already and it also
is an opportunity for us to rethink how
how we engage with work and the role of
working our lives which we were just
talking about but also maybe even the
power of the corporation in our lives
right so in the we've also discussed how
at least in the states um our benefits
and our lives are connected to
um our employer in ways that go beyond
just work
as you think about
the possibilities
created by the crisis
how would you want to reimagine
or redefine work
so if you could
wave a wand and make something different
what what would that what would it be
what would work look like
you know
five years from now after we've gone
through this
so i will i will throw that to
karen you can you can you can start us
off
i don't know if this really answers the
question but just a thought that's come
up by you or why we're saying that that
we have seen i've had a lot of
conversations over the last
you know year and a half with people who
were put into a position where they were
forced to suddenly from one day to the
next
be at home with their work
it was no prep time there was no like
people talk about this as a big
experiment
but
i mean it was an experiment born by
necessity
not through intention and careful
planning and
i think for what i would love to see
going into the next you know five years
is is
a lot of people that went into the
experiment
and embraced it and have come out of it
thinking wow this is definitely
something we're gonna do great there's
other people who went into it and just
grinned and bore it and thought this is
terrible we need to go back to the
office or whatever and i'd like to see
and then other people of course who did
it and then we're like forget it we're
you know maybe we're doing a hybrid
thing or whatever
um so different varieties of how people
are approaching work now
and what i'd like to see is for for the
folks that found it intriguing to sort
of take a step back
and approach
work out of the office with more
intention with more careful planning
to help
folks be more successful at it if that
makes sense
and what about you anu if you could wave
a wand and change how we work what would
that look like
well i think for me the biggest takeaway
has been the
the freedom that it has given
to me as an
employee and
and i think i'm sure it depends on what
line of work you're in and what your
hours are like in some jobs you have to
be there at a certain time
but it really has felt fantastic that
now it feels almost
imprisoning to think that every day i
would have to wake up and go to the
office you know regardless of
what the day is going to bring i mean
that was the expectation basically
before and i didn't think you know we
have a nice office and there's a lot of
nice people working there but now i feel
like i have so much more independence to
decide i can go to the office i can work
from home and everybody can see or has
seen
that most jobs can be handled like this
i'm sure there are companies that maybe
feel like this hurt their business model
and and people should be there at the
office more but overall it seems that we
actually after the initial shock adapted
really well and work can get done very
efficiently and
without having to commute without having
to travel which is good for the planet
too of course there's a discussion of
how much electricity we use and how it's
produced when we're all online but in
many ways i think
going forward since work life also has
to adapt to climate questions to
biodiversity challenges and so on
they could be good beneficial things for
us to feel that we have more control
over our work
it might make running our daily lives a
little easier and then it might also
hopefully save some of our planetary
resources if we can manage to sort of
combine
the face-to-face time that we talked
about earlier people actually being able
to see one another and get together but
at the same time keep that level of
trust
that people will actually work and they
will get the work done and they don't
have to show up at the office or be
there at a certain hour or
you know
wait until the boss leaves until you
dare to leave the office so
that i think would be
a wonderful thing if going forward we
could sort of build on that trust
between employers and employees and the
feeling that people can actually
decide how they arrange their work days
and that can be a good thing and work
can get done as long as we set those
boundaries that we talked about before
i know i know i said that was my last
question but i can't help myself i have
one more that was sparked by what you
both said
so
um the freedom sounds fantastic but not
everyone will have that
right so when we think about the economy
a lot of what we're discussing are for
people who are white collar workers or
you know information technology kind of
workers
do you worry that this will exacerbate
existing inequalities so i mean there's
already inequalities in terms of the
amount of money people make the amount
of status associated with the work they
do
and now we're going to what we're
talking about is freeing up
people's lives if
if what you all are talking about comes
to pass but not everyone's
life
how do you think about that and i'll
start with you on you because this is
really a high level social question and
i can imagine in nordic countries that
this could i don't i don't know how this
would be managed but what do you think
about the possibility of this
exacerbating existing inequalities
yeah that's a really good question i
mean obviously um
at first it seemed like the crisis is
really
showing us the value of
you know nurses doctors teachers the
people who are sort of the front line
workers that we talk so much about
but are we actually raising their
salaries are we actually in the end
doing anything to help them
give them more resources it seems that a
lot of them
actually are facing a burnout and and
are really struggling after this intense
period of time and the rest of us who
are here chatting about how wonderful it
is that that uh
workers being more independent living a
completely different reality so i think
that's a really important point of
course that work is not changing for all
of us
it does not give more freedom to all of
us and we really
should
divide resources in a way that allows
you know perhaps those people
some freedoms as well flexibility in
their hours or
the amount they work or at least their
paid parental leaves as well and so on
so that it doesn't just happen for the
people who are working like you were
saying in white-collar professions and
who are privileged in that way
and karen i don't know if you have any
thoughts about that
no i i mean it's an impossible yeah i
i think it's one of the things that
definitely i've read a few articles
about it over the last year and a half
yeah i mean i don't know what i don't
know what we do about it especially and
of course i'm sure like country globally
it's a different answer different places
too right
um it's kind of now as we're sort of in
this
you know the other the other sort of
inequality over the last
year and a half that we've seen at
automatic is
different countries are at different
stages of what's happening with covet
for example too you know so just kind of
seeing those
those inequalities of experience and
some people are able now to travel a
little bit and other people still aren't
and
you know
yeah i mean some people there's a lot of
people still really suffering from
what's going on in terms of still being
out of work and
yeah i know it's it's yeah go ahead go
ahead right i was just gonna add that i
think overall this is not really ready
to cove it but i think it would be
really important
especially in a country like the united
states to really focus on
what is the work life like for walmart
employees or amazon
you know workers
in this warehouses and so on
if in the nordic countries you look at
for example people who work at fast food
restaurants or something they still have
the same paid parental leave they still
have the same paid vacation days they
automatically have paid sick leave so
they're still inequalities of course and
in the nordic countries this is a real
concern as well which way are we going
and and income inequalities have grown
but there is so much that could be done
regardless of how covid changes work
life to just institute basic social
policies that give all workers certain
specific
rights that that really allow them to
combine work and family and that help
them also to leave more uh
what i would call freer lives regardless
of who the employer is or what type of
job it is or or how well educated you
are or so on yeah yeah well i i really
appreciate you both taking the time to
talk to me about it i mean it's there's
so many
opportunities but also a lot of
challenges ahead so i'm i'm happy to
spend the time talking with you and
thinking with you all about it so thanks
for for joining me
um so next week i'll be joined by roy
bahat the head of bloomberg beta and
mary kay henry the international
president of the service employees
international union to discuss
automation and the future of worker
rights so i hope i'll see you then
[Music]
you